le festival de cannes c'est le cinéma
bien sûr mais également les soirées les
organisateurs rivalisent d'audace pour
attirer les plus grandes stars et le
plus grand d'entre eux est certainement
jean sébastien roch tu veux sur un
événement offert niro fabrizzi les plus
renommés au monde
on connaît guetta on connaît tout le
monde fabrice va venir j'ai un petit peu
c'est gros attention à la marche
22 heures les premières stars commencent
à affluer à la soirée de l'année on
attend n'attend pas mal de monde on est
sûr de 800 personnes 22h30 le dj star
n'est toujours pas là
je tiens à paris
d'habitude on passé fabrice et évitez
juste pour faire un petit peu moins fort
la lumière pour fermer 10 ou plus
c'est mathématique physique mais sur des
aspects de la réforme
23h05 c'est le drame fabrizzi fait
l'échos ruche et s'écroule
trois pelés celui-ci
prendre car pour ça mais pour jean
sébastien roch la nuit ne fait que
commencer